menaces de nouvelles sanctions
américaines et pression vue d'arrêter la
construction du gazoduc nord stream de
ce sont les répercussions de la sphère
navalni au niveau international une
affaire qui a fait l'objet de nombreuses
filles news voici une liste non
exhaustive de ces fausses informations
qui circulent activement sur internet
navalni a été emprisonné pour avoir
défié poutine la justice russe a
transformé en peine de prison ferme
les trois ans et demi de prison avec
sursis prononcée en 2014 contre alexeï
navalni dans une affaire de détournement
de fonds communément appelée à faire
yves rocher avec son frère au legs neuf
années à persuader la filiale russe de
la compagnie cosmétique française de
recourir au service de leurs sociétés
écrans pour livrer des produits à des
coûts largement supérieur au prix du
marché
sa première condamnation toujours avec
sursis date de 2013
alexeï navalni a été condamné à cinq ans
de prison avec sursis dans le cadre
d'une affaire de fraude en lien avec
l'entreprise publique de production de
bois qui robles alexeï navalni compare
ici en février 2021 pour violations
multiples de son contrôle judiciaire en
2020 il devrait purger trois ans et demi
de prison de sa peine prononcée 1/2 14
où on les mois qu'il avait passé assigné
à résidence
cette année là soit deux ans et huit
mois de prison on reproche à navalni la
violation de sa période probatoire
alors qu'il était dans le coma alexeï
navalni ne s'était pas présenté au
contrôle judiciaire à six reprises au
cours de l'année 2020 le 13 janvier le
27 janvier
le 3 février le 16 mars le 6 juillet et
le 17 août les autorités pénitentiaires
ont pris en considération le temps passé
à l'hôpital de la charité de berlin
la direction du service fédéral
d'exécution des peines pour la ville de
moscou a pris en compte le fait qu'à
partir du 22 août 2020 alexeï navalni
suivait un traitement à l'hôpital de la
charité
cependant selon les informations
fournies par l'hôpital de la charité
alexeï navalni a quitté l'établissement
le 23 septembre 2020 or alexeï navalni
n'a pas répondu à la notification de
comparution à la filiale du service
fédéral d'exécution
et peine le 23 octobre 2020 et ne s'est
pas présenté à l'enregistrement la faire
yves rocher était une affaire politique
dans leur plainte auprès de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme alexia
navale et son frère alec demander de
considérer la sphère et brochets comme
une persécution politique
l'accord a déclaré cette partie de leur
requête est recevable
les requérants ont fait valoir que leur
poursuite pénale et condamnation avait
été motivée par des raisons politiques
et que ce mobile sous jacent avait
affecté chaque aspect de cette affaire
ils se sont référés à l'article 18 en
combinaison avec les deux articles de
fond invoqué dans cette affaire les
articles 6 et 7 de la convention
pour cette raison la plainte en vertu de
l'article 18 en combinaison avec les
articles 6 et 7 de la convention doit
être rejetée pour incompatibilité
ratione materiae avec les dispositions
de la convention
navalni a été innocenté par la cu dh
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
ne possèdent pas les compétences pour
innocenter ou déclarés coupables
il s'agit de trouver ou pas des
violations dans la procédure ce qui a
été fait dans la sphère navale n'est là
réussir même payer les dommages fixés
par la cndh dit à l'unanimité qu'il y
avait eu violation de l'article 6 alinéa
1 de la convention au titre d' absence
de procès équitable à l'égard des deux
requérants dit à l'unanimité qu'il y
avait eu violation de l'article 7 de la
convention à l'égard des deux requérants
les états unis veulent introduire de
nouvelles sanctions les chancelleries
européennes s'apprêtent à arrêter la
construction du gazoduc nord stream 2 à
cause de la sphère navalni mais est ce
une raison on prétexte